the other night Jenny bring an idea that
like as your parents are not uh
accepting us and all that so there's a
option that we should go and ship to
America like we should go to America
but going to America is big move so man
you have to let her understand that your
partner here you can work here you can
do your business here you have your
family here you have your friends here
are you willing to leave your parents
here and go to America
no actually I cannot even just even
think about it there is no way I can
feel like that I will go and shift to
America and live a peaceful life without
uh thinking about my parents
another thing which stopping me from
going to America is like uh maybe in
future I might uh wanted to have kids
[Music]
as my parents are worried about my
future they're thinking uh what if
you're gonna marry with Jenny you're not
going to have kids I I told them that
I can adopt or I can do surrogacy
this is what they want they want me to
have a secure future and a kid and
everything
this is a new thing that Sumit wants
kids it's very shocking news for me
because in their love story you know the
age difference and everything also
sumit's parents have problem with Jenny
now if Sumit will adopt a kid
um I don't know whether it will resolve
the things or make things more
complicated
have you ever talked to her
like whether she want a kid I'm not sure
whether Jenny wants to have kids or not
because we didn't have uh any any
conversation regarding this ever you
have to talk this also to Jenny
you have to understand each other now
also after marriage also you have to
understand each other yeah you have to
talk to her about going to America yeah
so you both have to think about this
also
together thank you
I don't want to go to America because I
know my life is here we are living a
better life here
the most important thing I feel like if
I go to America they're not going to
lose my family for good I lose my
friends I lose my work and like I lose a
life that I wanted
[Music]
thank you